temperatures warm up in the valley one
woman is making sure infants and
children are comfortable in the water
with life-saving skills to prevent
drowning victoria saha joins us live in
henderson tonight with a look at how
crucial it is to start infant swimming
resource lessons victoria
a crystal clear pool like this can be so
tempting to jump into but small children
may not know how dangerous it could be
and in a blink of an eye they can find
themselves under water if no one is
paying attention
most parents think swim lessons are the
only way to teach your child how to be a
confident swimmer and stay above the
water but infant swimming resource also
known as isr is a crucial program that
teaches infants and young children how
to save themselves in the water by
breathing exercises and instant reflexes
like rolling onto your back instructor
jessica tuck says she starts teaching
infants as young as six months old
i have known people that have lost
kiddos to drownings amazing wonderful
parents who
love their kids and are attentive
parents and it still happens it happens
to good parents all the time
my boys did isr before i became an
instructor and i absolutely fell in love
with the program
safety doesn't just stop at the lessons
she says parents have to be very careful
and always make sure there are locked
gates surrounding a pool and if you're
having a gathering make sure there's
always a designated person to have an
eye on the children around the water
each lesson is about 10 minutes long
monday through friday for six weeks if
you are looking for an instructor make
sure they are certified we will have
more information up on our website at
8newsnow.com reporting live from
henderson tonight victoria saha live
local now